this crazy ideology is creating
absurdities so one of my favorite videos
going around the internet from these
demonstrations and protests is you have
this Hispanic guy who's wearing a
t-shirt it says God guns and Trump and
he's standing there you know where he
stands some white liberal guy walks up
to him and starts arguing with him and
the Trump supporter flips the tables on
the white liberal he's trying to come up
with an answer to this where is it you
want to get you want you want me to
preparations where are my reparations
the guys agreeing the white liberals
agree yes you do
that's right I'm fighting for
reparations but I'm not gonna give them
to you and then the Hispanic Trump's
persist so what are we even talking
about he just calls him out he calls out
the hypocrisy says okay you want you
want me to have reparations right yes I
want you to have reparations
you think I'm oppressed right yes I
think you're oppressed okay well do it
put up or shut up give me give me my
reparations well no I'm not I don't want
to do that oh okay so this is all this
is all just a game I mean I don't think
that this white liberal meant to show
this point or meant to concede this
point but what he is showing here is
that all this racial agitation is simply
a political tool it's a an exploitative
tool to affect their ideological ends
[Music]
you
[Music]